안녕하세요 시루입니다 제가 영상들에
달린 댓글을 다 챙겨 보려고 해요
그런데 제가 올렸던 첫 영상인 겨울
아우터 관련 내용에 이런 댓글이
달렸었다 사실 예상했던 댓글입니다
그런데 제가 정말 겨울에 이렇게
입어요 그래서 감기에 걸렸었나 봅니다
패딩이 하나 있긴 한데 좀 부해지는
거 싫어해서 자주 안 입고 무엇보다
제가 더위를 많이 타서 지하철 탔을
때 땀이 확 나는 걸 안 좋아합니다
그래서 상인은 벗을 수 있게 여러
겹을 레이어링해서 입고 하이는 내복을
입는 대신에 좀 두툼한 바지 몇 개를
돌려 입어요 오늘 소개할 친구들은
제가 겨울에 이렇게 정말 잘 입고
있는 바지입니다 오늘 소개할 바지들이
보시고 완전 똑같은 건 아니더라도 아
이런 겨울 바지들 괜찮구나 하면서 참
하시면 좋을 것
같습니다 처음 소개할 바지는 리엘의
이사 FW 캐슬락 코듀로이
트라우저입니다이 바지는 최근에 구매한
바지 중 하난데 겨울에 많이들
입으시는 코듀로이 소재예요로 게이지로
돼 있어서 좀 더 굵직한 선들로 돼
있습니다 가격대가 좀 있어 가지고
엄청 고민하다가 아 이런 색감에이
실루엣의 마음에 드는 바지를 더는 못
찾겠더라고요 그래서 시즌 프
들어가자마자 텐꼬르소 꼬모에서
구매했습니다 꽤나 인기가 많은지 이게
해외에서도 대부분 품절이더라고요
제가 소개했던 리엘의 워커 자켓과
동일한 캐슬 락이라는 색상명 되어
있는데 자켓보다 좀 더 진한
회색입니다 약간 녹색 빛도 돌아요
와이드하지도 않고 그렇다고 딱 붙지도
않는 호로 갈리기 어려운 일자 통의
바입니다 요즘은 이렇게 리에르워
자켓이랑 세트로 많이 입습니다 진짜
겨울에 거의 이렇게밖에 안 입은 거
같아요 회사 선배가 심지어 교복이라고
하더라고요 자켓 안에 스웨터 하나
있고 그 위에 비슷한 회색톤의
바람막이를 입어주는 조합이 조합
때문에 미안하게도 옷장에 다른 옷들에
손을 잘 못 대고
있습니다 르니까 리르 같이 많이 입고
있는데 날씨가 좀 풀리면 세의
반팔이나 니트류와 조합해도 충분히
예쁠 것
같습니다 참고로 제가 허리가 30
정도인데이 제품은 스몰 사이즈 가니까
딱
좋더라고요 다음 소개할 겨울 바지는
더로우 코듀로이 팬츠입니다이 바지는
회사 선배한테 구매한 제품이라서
정확한 제품 명이랑 시즈는 잘
모르겠어요 앞선 리엘의 코드레이
팬츠와 차이점이라면이 바지는 좀 더
하이 게이지로 돼 있어서 코드로의
선이 더 가늘고 촘촘합니다
그리고 레귤러 단 슬림한 바지에
가까워요 그래서 이바지 입을 땐
상해도 좀 정 피스로 입으려고 합니다
안 그러면이 상하체가 너무 불균형해진
제가 유일하게 가진 더러운데 확실히
더로우 예쁘긴 합니다이 제품은
캐시미어 혼방으로 된 제품이라 굉장히
부드럽더라고요
기장수선을 해
아직 이게 너무 아까워 가지고 접고
다니고
있어요 리에르 더로우 제품 모두
코드로이지만 게이지 차이 때문에
분위기 차이가 꽤 큽니다 리에는 더
두툼한 로우
게이지라인 분위기가 조금 더 강하다면
더러 오는 실루엣도 가늘고 하이
게이즈라 좀 더 섹시한 연출에 사용할
수 있는 바입니다 상위는 지난 연말에
제가 자주 입은 조합인 빨간 울
셔츠와 라운드넥 가디건이에요 지난
영상에도 이렇게 입었었는데 최근에
제가 좀 자주 하는 레이어링 있니다
좀 연말 느낌도 불신하고 안쪽 컬러가
포인트가 되어서 마음에 들더라고요
저는 여름 제하고는 레이어링을 많이
하는데 나중에 이것도 한번 다뤄보려고
합니다 세 번째로 소개할 겨울 바지는
장폴고티에 efw 페티 슈트
팬츠입니다이 바지는에 에서 아울렛이라
때 구매를 했어요 사이즈가 스몰만
남아서 엄청 고민하다가 구매를 했는데
다행히도 잘 맞습니다 좀 편하게
입으려면 살을 빼긴 해야 할 거
같아요이 제품은 제가 처음으로 구매한
장폴고티에 제품입니다 처음
에딕티드에서 발매했을 때부터 눈 여겨
봤었는데 사실 그 장폴고티에 구매했다
그보다는 단순히 이바지가 상당히
마음에 들어 가지고 구매를 했어요이
제품 자체는 장폴고티에 그
젠더리스한 비전형이 잘 느껴지는
제품은 아닙니다이 제품과 셋업으로
나온 봄버자켓 있는데 그 제품은 좀
장폴고티에 향이 강하긴 해요 이바지는
두툼한 페이티드 울로 되어 있다는
점이 가장 마음에 들었어요 페이티드
울은 직조를 조이기 위해서 세탁하고
축소한 직조 약입니다 그래서 일반 원
보다 좀 더 단단하고 각도 잘 잡히고
통기성도
적어요이 바지는 제가 영상속 장처럼
정말 많이 입고 다니고 있는데요이
바진 비슷한 색감의 자켓이나 인너
등이랑 자주 붙여서 입고 있습니다
제가 차콜 색에 무난하고 단순한
상이가 많은데 그 제품들이랑 톤으로
조합하기 용이한 제품이더라고요 위에
입은 건 제가 앞선 상에서 소개했던
르메르의 이사 FW 더블 브레스티드
숏
코트입니다이 바진 보온성도 상당히
좋아서 제가 이번 겨울에 가장 잘
입고 다니는 바지 중 하나로
등극했습니다 마지막으로 소개할 겨울
바지는 라프시몬스의 2 AW 워크웨어
팬츠입니다 이건 사실 여자 바지예요
대신에 사이즈가 3이라서 제 허리에
맞더라고요이 제품은 좀
까슬까슬한 단으로 되어 있습니다 장폴
고티 만큼은 아니지만 그래도 따뜻한
바지예요이 바지는 위에 소개한
더러운나라 캐주얼한 느낌이 강합니다
올로 되어 있고 스트라이프 디테일이
있다는 점에서 좀 클래식한 느낌도
분명히 있긴 해요 다만 오른쪽 허벅지
뒤쪽에 있는이 포켓이 캐주얼한 느낌을
강하게 줍니다 그 디키즈의 워크웨어
펜들을 보면 뒤편에 로고랑 포켓 같이
있잖아요 이게 디 키즈에서 영감을
받아서 이렇게 만든 건지는 잘
모르겠지만 우리가 흔히 하는
라프시몬스의 RS 적힌 큼직한 로고
대신에 작게 라프 시몬스가 주머니와
함께 적혀 있어요 흔한 로고가
아닌지라이 점이 개인적으로 마음에
들었습니다 이곳저곳에 막 붙여봤는데
아무래도 캐주얼한 느낌이 좀 더 강한
바지인 지라 비슷한 느낌의 제품들
이거 잘 어울리더라
자체유도 분명히 좋긴 해요 그런데
저는 지금 입은 것처럼 파타고니아의
신칠라 후리스 같은 캐주얼 제품과
자주 입습니다 스트라이프로 되어 있는
울 팬츠랑 겨울 느낌도 강하고
스니커즈 터 로퍼 6까지 같이 신었을
때 다
괜찮더라고요 새해를 맞이해서 이렇게도
찍어보고 저렇게도 찍어 보면서 더
좋은 영상 만들어 보기 위해 연구하고
있는 요즘입니다
어이 영상을 만드는 동안 날씨가 많이
추워졌는데 다들 감기 조심하시길
바랍니다 오늘 제 이야기는
여기까지입니다 감사합니다